we had this debate a little bit over
cigarettes right they canceled Joe Camel
about I don't know 15 years ago because
the cartoon image of the camel was
thought to appeal to children and so the
maker of those cigarettes I can't
remember which company made Capital
makes Campbell it's just it's just camo
they got rid of Joe Camel and for that
reason because even though it wasn't
appearing in children's media kids were
seeing the Joe Camel and thinking okay
there's this cartoon that they associate
with cigarettes but you know let's be
real like James Bond was a bigger
influence in getting kids to smoke than
Joe Camel was if I was 20 I wasn't
seriously I was an actor in my early 20s
I mean I'm still an actor but I was in
Hollywood for a lot of that and if I'd
booked a Bud Light commercial at the age
of 25 and people went nuts on me because
some of my fans were 16 and 17. that's I
would be out of my mind pissed off at
them yeah I'm over 21 man I'm selling
beer right but that's not it Dylan
Mulvaney is on Tick Tock with 11 million
followers and outside of Dylan Mulvaney
the average Tick-Tock user is 20 years
old